this mural is one of thousands in
Philadelphia
they're in yuppie Rittenhouse Square and
working-class fish town near the Liberty
Bell and in West Philly - why does
Philly have so many murals and how did
they make it happen it's not just
because they're pretty though they are
that murals aren't paintings but tools
that create wealth employ people and can
help reimagines any city one wall at a
time
[Music]
at broaden Spring Garden you'll find
Meg's salad men's common threads across
the street from that near-great
you'll find this humble pole this is
kind of the thing that started Philly's
obsession with murals graffiti it was
all like an unknown world to me and
anyway but it was also like super
exciting
Jane golden founded Billy's mural arts
program she came to Philadelphia from LA
where she'd painted more than 50 murals
she was hired in the 1980s to work as a
part of mayor Wilson goods anti graffiti
Network people saw graffiti as a plague
so the idea was to stop graffiti by
recruiting graffiti artists to make
murals he had met me back then my
colleagues have been baby rock and nice
and cool and disco duck it was like it
was unbelievable it was it was so great
I like fell in love with Philadelphia
through the eyes of young people and
community leaders here's dr. J in a suit
he looks good
right when this mural was painted in
1990 people were certain it would be
defaced with graffiti when it wasn't it
proved an anti graffiti strategy murals
could serve as an artistic shield
against vandalism that's become a model
for lots of cities nationwide at the end
of the day it was like the perfect
vehicle to really move these kids from
where they were to another point without
being like a fascist or a dictator or
too prescriptive but for Philly to grow
into a city with thousands of murals it
took a total transformation not just for
the city but for the program that
covered it two murals need money mural
arts scrambles to get it that was the
case with common threads when Meg
Seligman approached Jane Gould and with
an idea she could view a funding and I
was like me not really
I said behind funding she said really
and I was like yeah so she said okay
well guess what I got a grant from
National Endowment of the Arts was a
grant for however much money okay that's
that will be our start so I went and I
found some money from the city and we
put that in a pot then we applied to a
few little foundations and we got some
grants and then we trust' raising money
and run out of money and then it would
be like half way we'd be like oh my god
we've been raising more money and I
remember we like got further down then
further down the wall and then finally a
river guide cheney's working the
Philadelphia Foundation he had a check
for us for $5,000 and he drove up to the
loaners and here's your check and allow
this definition sir hold it that
scramble was only possible because in
the mid 90s mural arts restructure to
use both public and private money the
organization brings in an average of $1
15 private funds for every dollar it
gets from the city I think our key
ingredient is a leveraging of public and
private funds because without those
sectors at work we would do less work
and I think having the long term support
of the city has really ensured our
longevity that means that get city perks
like the historic building that's home
to the program but it also seeks private
dollars to pay for more artists and
materials and that money doesn't just
change a city's colors it changes its
character too let's say you don't care
about theater of life on Lombard abroad
or one world just over on 16th the walls
are just part of the program murals can
boost property values in combat blight
that common threads building today it's
being marketed as the mural lofts
people see those murals too in 2014
tours of the city brought 15,000 people
to see the murals with 65% leaving the
center of the city to see more
neighborhoods across the street from
common threads you'll find a mural on a
school in addition to employing artists
mural arts includes education programs
for about a thousand students neural
Arts also designed some programs
specifically for artists with mental
health and substance abuse challenges
the Yale School of Medicine found that
this public art helped Public Health in
the mural art scale
program for formerly incarcerated
individuals reduce the rate of return to
prison the laundry list of benefits is
impressive but these murals are really
about communities expressing themselves
whether it's a photorealistic picture of
a legendary pool player or a modern
collage featuring icons like the roots
the goal is to help communities make the
city their city whether they like
Shepard Fairey or Keith Haring or Frank
Sinatra what we want is for the
community to be okay with it right to be
inspired by it to have it so that it has
meaning for them and then all of it
together it's like this giant crescendo
that really speaks to the importance of
not just beauty but beauty does have
important but also representation and
how that representation happens it can
happen all different ways how great is
that that we get to experience all these
different narratives that in the end
speak about our lives but isn't that
what art does that it shines a light on
our diversity but lifts up our
commonality and in the end connects us
to all that makes issue I think at the
end of the day that probably inspires me
almost more than anything I am I am a
very serious law hunter this means that
no matter where I am no matter what city
I am in I will know this really good
blank wall
you